good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the Planning Committee this
evening note this is a public meeting
but it is only those to participate only
those who are registered to speak those
who have registered to speak will be
given the opportunity invited for to do
so within their allotted time slots in
due course I will ask the committee to
introduce themselves and if I can ask
that any other comments anyone who isn't
registered speak doesn't comment so I'd
like to move to introductions thank you
my name is David Jeffrey I'm the Western
team leader in my role as an impartial
adviser to the committee I can clarify
any planning issues they're eyes doing
so I am bound by the code of conduct of
the Royal Town Planning Institute
planning committee members are not bound
by the case officers recommendations or
by oral advice steer flarty planning
officer Victoria chatter a Senior
Planner Alan about us planning officer
Sara McPherson assistant planner thank
you um can i clarify whether there are
any apologies for absence now I move to
item 2 which is disclosure for interests
before I invite the rest of the
committee to comment we as a committee
or some of the committee members
attended a site visit in relation to the
first application which is in relation
to the Old Rectory some documentation
involving photographs with some comment
on was distributed a copy of that is
with the planning officers I can confirm
that no that material influenced me and
I come to this committee with an open
mind and I would ask any committee
member who attended that site visit
and who doesn't consider themselves to
be of an open mind to declare that and
not to sit on that certification and I
would at this stage invite any other
committee member to indicate whether
they have any interest to disclose um in
relation to the minutes committee are
you satisfied that they are a proper
record of the meetings held on the 23rd
of May under the 13th of June committees
happy for me to sign those then can I
raise a point of order there yes so just
before this meeting you were advising
some of us but we shouldn't be using our
mobile phones or these two part of the
phone whether we have a valid reason to
or not I just want to clarify is that
you love you or is that actually a rule
of the planning committee my view as
chair of committee today is that mobile
phone use should be restricted when the
committee is receiving important
information relevant to their
deliberation so when an officer is
speaking or when a member of public is
speaking this is absolutely clear this
is your subjective view as someone who's
chairing a meeting for the first time
it's my suggestion that it would be in
proper order to understand and respect
that suggestion yes indeed and it's a
matter for you councilor Vaudrey how you
choose to conduct yourself within this
meeting okay I'm glad that's been
clarified thank you right if we could
now move to item 4 on the agenda that is
application number 18 slash zero zero
six for 1/4 the Old Rectory
and I will invite the relevant office to
present the application thank you
Thank You chair good evening this is a
full play application for the
construction of an out building within
the curtilage of a listed dwelling
incorporating the Orangery greenhouse
pool house and walled garden the
proposed building will house a
greenhouse swing pool and related
accommodation envisioned to a boiler
room existing pathways towards the
proposal will also be slightly altered
to provide the access to the new walled
garden there are two outbuildings there
all
to be demolished his pot hosel in
addition three trees would also be
removed as a result of development just
as a means of protocol at the start this
application was deferred from the last
West planning commentary committee on
13th of June to allow for a slight visit
to take place this site visit took place
at 5:00 p.m. on Tuesday the 3rd July
2018 with councilors Atkins Barnes Giles
and Richards in attendance also in
attendance where the applicant mr.
Barnes Dale in addition to mr. Richard
Parr and his colleague from Richard Parr
associates more detail mr. site visit is
provided in your update sheets which has
been disputed as detailing the update
and if nobody has been rented by the
chair mr. Pryor disputed a photo during
pack with accompanying text to detail
the merits of proposed scheme at the
time of the visits now moving to the
presentation this application site lies
in the verge of King Wharton with an
open countryside and to the east of the
market town of Ulster identified by the
black dots here on your screen besides
in a rural location within the West
Midlands greenbelts in addition to being
within designated odd and special
landscape area want me to say that
there's also a public footpath which
perhaps is more viewable on the next
slide but it's highlighted here and it
dotted Green on this slide the Old
Rectory which word that runs past the
Old Rectory and pass the towards a tough
coach which we'll see you in a future
slide shortly the southwestern part of
the site is also in flood zones 2 & 3
within the flood plain of the river all
looking now at a satellite image this
site is located off who Mill Road
accessed of the v40 89 captain's Hill as
you've missed a flat image you can see
here the river all banded some to
southeast of the sites this application
site is outlined here in red one can see
the orientation of the site in relation
to the greatest are listed sit marries a
virgin Church glebe farm and other farm
buildings and dwellings in the wider
vicinity we also see the siting of the
proposed outbuilding approximately 20
meters to the north east of the main
house the or directory and positioned on
the sides of an existing old tennis
court
here we have the existing site plan in
more detail this clearly shows again the
orientation of the nesting sites
relationship to its surroundings
here we have the proposed site plan
clearly illustrating the footprint of
the existing tennis courts which you can
see hopefully on the dotted line here on
the plan in addition to two timber
outbuildings here to the east of the
existing tennis courts which are
proposed to be demolished as part of
this two proposal here we have proposed
south and north elevations of the
proposed or our building in addition to
the east and west elevations and here we
can see a ground floor plan of the
proposed I now move to some photos of
the sites and the surroundings here we
are standing in the rear of the garden
of the Old Rectory looking at the rear
elevation looking Northwest woods as we
stood here
okay standing in a similar position we
can now see the existing tennis courts
sorry now looking at north or eastwards
towards a proposed sighting of the
outbuilding here we can see the entry
points of the existing tennis courts one
can see that they are somewhat overgrown
and not currently in use here we are now
stood on the testicle itself looking
back westwards towards the main dwelling
a great crazy listed dwelling one can
also see the church in the far right of
this image here the spire and a little
bit of the building elements here to the
far right here we are now on the front
drive with the main dwelling positioned
did a setback and lower level to the
greatest are listed Church here now we
are looking at the application site
looking westwards from the king Wharton
dovecotes
one can see one can see that there is
mature vegetation that isn't fully fat
the time of this photo that largely
screens the application sites on the
northern boundary and finally a similar
view but taken from slightly further
back again on the public footpath one
could see the wider setting and
topography other sites that concludes my
slides chair I would just like to point
people in direction again appeal a sheet
which has been prepared to detail what
was described what the detail be site
visit that's it place yesterday chair
the recommendation is to refuse this
application for the reason set out pages
26 and 27 of the agenda thank you Thank
You Stuart
and we don't have any speakers
registered in relation to the town
counts or Parish Council or objectors so
if I could invite the applicant and
agent to speak on why the tables in
front
thank you so when indicated you have
three minutes from when you start and I
will give you a 30-second warning
thank you your time is coming to an end
I will think use of the cancers for
agreeing to you and organizing the site
visit yesterday and I hope that the
findings can be shared with the other
campuses who are unable to attend but I
believe there were many benefits of that
visit and I think it was a good idea
that it took place I would like to think
that added clarity to the proposal
showing these showing the position of
the building on the site the heights and
the scale within which was demonstrated
by facsimile at the building erected by
my client with red tape and posts it
also defined the enclosure and the way
the proposal was tucked into the site it
showed the scale and appropriateness in
relation to the old rectory in church
and hopefully proved why the scheme
should be allowed approval under very
special circumstances but in considering
this I'd ask you to please recall the
report prepared by the conservation
officer where she gave warm support and
also I was quoting one of the cancers
comments here in conclusion I believe
the benefit of the orangie to the listed
buildings overcomes the construction in
the Greenbelt I believe that this is
sufficient special reason to grant
planning consent and obviously open to
any questions that you might wish to ask
um if I could just point out that
Georgian properties of this magnitude
and type was quite normal to have walled
gardens with them and it's really may I
suggest wrong that the planning officers
should say that esna describes the trio
of the church former rectory and mature
beech tree as a happy trio and she
believes that to introduce an
outbuilding of such scale and grandeur
would in my view compete with this happy
trio when the people when everybody came
to the visit last yesterday evening it
was quite obvious that from the view
that you see of the curve of the pool
house the
Church is nowhere in sight and therefore
I would suggest you that this is looking
very much like another trio that you see
you see the coach-house you see the
actual rectory and you see the The
Orangery at the same time totally
different much lower two meters as we
showed lower compared with the church
they don't conflict or at harm you
couldn't see hardly anything of the of
the pool house and really I would just
like to hope that you will grant this
because it will significantly improve
the the property as at the moment it
just needs something there to fill this
area and to replace a redundant tennis
court thank you you've perfectly filled
your time slots I thank you very much
committee do you have any questions for
the applicant and agent councillor
Richards
thank you you said two meters does that
mean that buildings dug in it's actually
lower down on the site visit actually my
client had put a piece of tape which
actually was on the the level of the
pavement to the church and that defined
the level that that that was a datum
level that showed the relation of the
new proposal to the church so we're not
talk about the height of the buildings
we talk about the height of the ground
which as you say is set two meters below
the level of the entrance of the church
yeah sure thank you not quite so
obviously I saw that piece of tape I
know that how the levels were the level
of the tennis court is going to be the
base that's two meters further down yeah
that's two meters further down okay
that's fine
and just so I'm clear the tennis court
how a how long has it been there be were
there existing buildings on that site
prior to the tennis court whether these
slides that were just flick through
showed that there were previous
buildings that on the site behind the
church and so it was a sort of service
yard to the house accessed by another
we're the gatepost is still in existence
on the other side the church and the
tennis court believe has been there for
50 years 50 years it's about that
presume where you've got presumed
building on site is that little sort of
u-shape upside-down U shape
well actually the buildings are slightly
closer to that they were on that site
and towards left towards the church it's
approximately right yes yes yes thank
you you've heard the questions committee
level three my apologies I couldn't make
it yesterday and look when I look at the
pictures of what you're proposing to do
from last time you know it's very nice
but where I sit here struggling and I'm
looking for your explanation is because
it's in the Greenbelt what is the key
reason that we can justify this within
the Greenbelt that's why I struggle on
this is the only thing I'm struggling
with but if I can just have you also
best attempt of trying to help me over
that hurdle I think there are two key
reasons one is actually it's an area of
within the coffers of the listed
building which has been very much
polluted by hard tennis court high
netting and there are two outbuildings
green house and sheds which sprawl down
the site and the idea is actually to
condense all that within the tennis
court area so it will actually clean up
the site and smaller buildings that
that's one benefit the other the other
is that that was an area of the site
which always had been inhabited it all
the tennis court was built on an
unsecured area of outbuildings and the
setting of these buildings as you will
benefit from having that corner of the
site almost reinstated the probably was
a wall some element of wall garden there
that definitely were outbuildings that
definitely were some areas and ciliary
to the main house so in this Chuck -
juxtaposition of historical buildings it
seems a a really good opportunity to
complete the site and remove any of
these blemishes and replace it with
among the final reason there's actually
the the the proposal we've put together
is a really high-quality beautiful
design that actually sits subservient to
but enhances the the principle
house which is the rectory on the site
is that is that helpful I think it's an
opportunity to complete that site excuse
me sorry if I could I think it was a
quite full answer to question oh that's
fine
I think councillor witches have got
another for you as well thank you you
talk about two other buildings on the
site are they to be removed yes the
demolition is shown on the application
any others no I brought you back to your
seat thank you very much
okay committee we now have an
opportunity for you to ask any further
questions you would like to of the
offices and I invite you to do so if you
wish class
along the same lines obviously with the
site visit and I suppose the feedback
from counselors as they saw it obviously
in the paper the recommendation is to
refuse is that you've heard the answer
from the gentleman is there anything
that would you've heard today that would
make query the the original assumption
about the balance between being in the
green belt and and the desirability of
this building it's very much a very
eloquent answer given by the African the
agent I believe the fundamental I think
as you alluded to in your original
question of the principle of a
development here within the green belt
setting the the benefit may well give to
the Heritage setting not which then
notwithstanding the consideration of the
green belt balance is still very much of
paramount importance I would say and
there are various different tests that
would need to be adhered to and the
issue for debate for yourselves is
whether not this introduction had built
form in this Greenbelt setting is if you
were to go with officers opinion over
the states that is inappropriate form of
development within the green belt and
it's yeah the key test here really is
the impact on the openness of the green
belt we've in our view assessed this
application and consider that it is and
if inappropriate development in the
green belt in appropriate development by
definition is harmful to the green belt
and its openness and needs to be
demonstrated that there are very special
circumstances for such development to be
allowable the key here is in the phrase
very special circumstances these are
circumstances which should be rare
exceptional in nature and should
deliver some significant social or
economic benefit to the wider community
in the public it is for the applicant to
demonstrate very special circumstances
we are mindful of the comments of the
conservation officer this is an
application which can be supported but
we threshold has been passed counsel
Atkinson at the a site visit yesterday
was the officer satisfied that the tapes
which were spread across the site where
a relevant factor in the height of this
work which had to be done well what was
it in your XP relevant and accurate
thank you I believe the tapes that were
put in place whilst an informative I
believe the gentleman mentioned about
that the floor levels of the church the
the tape that was in place on the site
was more towards I understood it to be
more the the height of the maximum war
we can see here on this elevation and
for example wooden have included the
additional roof light element on top so
the degree to which that was a
representative of what the built form
would eventually be word to be approved
I'm not as convinced that was a true
representation of the height and scale
of what would be proposed and what would
be their if approved as evening would be
my view sorry chairman hi
could you just explain that again I
didn't quite hear you accurately is it a
fair reflection of the height of the
work which has to be done there in my
view not a truly fair reflection of the
what would be the height of the proposed
out building no though he might know it
no it would not be a true reflection of
what would be the eventual height of the
building if bill tells
come sir bombs there was a tennis court
there with metal things all the way
around to two and half meters high
now that presumably hadn't got climbing
permission with them before planning or
I mean that will be taken again yeah of
course it will just be approved tennis
court the ring front element would be
removed yes for this proposed
outbuilding to be put in place with
regards to whether or not the planning
was in place there's a planning history
included in your reports not for the
tennis courts note again the gentleman
at the applicant mentioned the tennis
court have been there for approximately
I believe said fifty years it will take
I can't speak to any business that you
know planning history relating to that
but I can't speak to that's I'm afraid
if I could discuss a question in fact
David you were talking about the test
and I just wanted to clarify if for
example you talked about very special
circumstances needing to be exceptional
and obviously there's a scale of special
circumstances and some are going to be
stronger than others is it fair that the
test
you could say well you may you may have
special circumstances which are very
special and cross the line but aren't at
the very top of that scale but equally
you have harm which is not very harmful
you allowed to draw a balance in that
way or is it that you just need to be
satisfied that those special
circumstances are there fair summation
would be that the greater the harm to
the openness of the green belt the
greater the special circumstances would
need to be a mindful that I may have
implied that special circumstances must
be an individual but it can be the case
that I elements or the development which
individually would not amount to very
special circumstances can cumulatively
amount to special circumstances
thing that members can bear in mind but
with any further questions what if I
could invite members to debate the issue
comes Laban's yes madam chairman I think
the start visit to me was very very
useful I didn't really know the size I
looked at the papers originally thought
this is definitely refusal and after
looking at the things and like the chat
pass chairman I said some comments like
I'll give it a whirl on the side visit I
was more supportive than I was actually
a committee I think a lot of work
pre-application work had been done on me
from what we were sold the conservation
architect was fully support of it I
think the long lines and the bits of
tape were in the correct place and as
far as I'm concerned then I obviously
don't want a lot of buildings in the
green belt but this is only a tennis
court it is in a secluded area as you
know we did go and look all the way
around it and I would be happy to
propose councillor Atkinson yes I'm very
happy to second what Council of bonds
has said certainly with a structure of
this nature had this being built at the
time there would be no problem
I cannot from the site visit see that
there is any difficulty with the
openness of the Greenbelt
having walked it on a number of
occasions and seen the dovecote where
the monks put the pigeons it just to me
has no difficulty whatsoever
as far as the openness of the Greenbelt
which in certain interpretation is quite
an abstract factor so I certainly second
our second council of bonds proposal
which I think interpreted as an approval
to the application Thank You counsel
Joss all happy contributor debate is
Greenbelt it is a balancing act partly
based on the comments from my colleagues
who went to the site visit and I didn't
and partly because when you do look at
it from the those other buildings are
being removed and the tennis court you
know I think it's it's wrong for us to
sit here and say we shouldn't do it so
make sure I'm very happily concur with
councillor Atkins and Barnes I would
support the development of this albeit
in the green belt albeit I hate doing
things in the green belt but actually on
balance this is it's gonna be probably
better than it was so I'm happy to take
the evidence provided and I'll be
supporting house the Barnes if he goes
to face councillor Richards thank you
you've canceled there and so I'll try
and sort of expand on the reasons why my
colleagues are moving in the way they
are and there are two reasons for
objection one is harm to heritage and
visual harm on page 23 the case officer
does say that she doesn't think there is
harm to the heritage assets which is a
good start
she goes on to say on the flooring
patients web page 24 that she does feel
that there is some visual harm now
having had the benefit of the site visit
knowing the topography of the area how
far down in this site the proposed sits
I actually disagree with that I don't
think there will be a negative impact as
a result of the visuals so I'm
discounting that reason for objection it
doesn't mean we still have this
Greenbelt which my colleagues have tried
to address I don't think they've
specifically said any particular special
circumstances so I will try to do that
now
in my view the proposed is of
exceptional design and would in fact
enhance the listed building and the
views of the site there is evidence as
we've seen of buildings that have
existed on the site that no longer do
and we are also seeing the removal of
existing buildings from the site so to
my view and this is very specific to
this site to my view the exceptional
design that seeks to mirror the style of
the existing properties and enhances the
the listed buildings and the setting is
one special circumstance and the
evidence of buildings that have existed
and removal therefore a not a
significant increase in massing is
another what I would suggest is that we
if I would be looking to grant as well
but I would suggest that we add the
removal of PD to prevent the those
buildings that are being removed coming
back at a later date without the need
for planning before it come to the vote
and I think counsel of Audrey has
identified the issue correctly which is
there is an interference with the green
boat in the openness and so I think it
is necessary to identify those very
special circumstances and I have to say
I'm inclined I certainly agree with
counselor Richards that I was satisfied
from the site visit that with the
conservation officers opinion about lack
of harm to the heritage assets because
of the nature of where it is and it's so
sunk down it can't be seen from the
front
I agree actually about visual harm we
spent a lot of time around the footpaths
in the winter I suspect it could be seen
a little bit more but I I think in light
of the levels I think it would have a
limited impact and so for me I think
it's about looking at whether those
special circumstances that have been
identified by Council Richard
cumulatively outweigh what I would say
is lower down the scale of harm given
given the exceptional quality of design
and the fact that it will enhance I
think will enhance a listed building so
what I want to do is I think I just want
to pass two offices to clarify because I
I understand that proposers been made by
councillor Barnes
seconded by councillor Atkinson so I I
invite council bonds but are you
suggesting that your reason
in line with those that have been
outlined and expressed by councillor
Richards yes ma'am I think you know it
is an exceptional of design and it is
appropriate in that space and I think
that is the important thing if it have
been a block of flats we did yesterday
but well laughs as you might bilities it
does fit right and I think that's like
cancer Richard said those reasons I
don't really want to go through the
reason for materials and all that but
I'm sure that can be dealt with later so
I just like to invite you to deal with a
summary of the reasons and whether there
any issues in relation to conditions
that need to be raised and also the
issue that was raised by councillor
Richards about removal of PD rights
absolutely happy to do that Thank You
chair yes so just to I don't know my
understanding he's indicated to support
for the application but no he's not
registered to speak yeah
just just to clarify some of the
elements of the debate that I've heard
in respective heritage we are satisfied
that the proposed development is broadly
acceptable that it's actually improving
the significance of the listed buildings
by removing existing outbuildings and by
providing something which looked well in
place and is appropriate in scale and
kind and purpose in respect to the
Greenbelt I just want to be really clear
in terms of the debate because there was
some mixed comments in terms of the
visual impact one of the things about
the openness of the Greenbelt is that it
is separate to the visual impacts that
may arise from any development I think
broadly comments were aligned that this
is in members view in appropriate
development in the Greenbelt
but that very special circumstances do
exist
and again those arise from the
exceptional quality of the proposed
development that it does occur the
removal of out buildings and there's an
appropriateness about the proposed use
and design of the building the last
element of this application which
members discussed was the visual impact
and there was a recommended reason for
refused long landscaped grounds but
members have viewed the site on a site
visit and have considered the scale of
the proposed building and its setting
adjacent to the listed building and
within the wider area and consider that
those factors are broadly in accordance
with the development plan and that on
that basis a recommendation of approval
you'd like to vote upon in respective
conditions for that offices would
consider a three year implementation
samples for brickwork so that we can
secure not just the size of the brick
but the type of mortar and so on
material samples to be submitted and the
panel to be erected on-site large-scale
details of the windows and doors to be
provided and agreed the outbuildings
ancillary to the main use of the
dwelling we think we should secure that
by condition so that it can't fall into
some alternative use we also would
recommend the demolition of the existing
outbuildings to be a requirement of the
planning permission and lastly following
from the conversations a removal of PD
rights for within the curtilage of these
buildings Council bonds are you happy
for those conditions to be added to your
proposal yes I am
it can't really be seen in open
countryside oh yes I think that was the
summary of the reason was that we didn't
consider to have a significant visual
impact or negative impact
therefore if counselors we have a
proposal to grunt in relation to
application 1800 640 1/4 and all those
in favor please show thank you therefore
this committee resolves to grant the
application
committee we now turn to application 18
/ 0 0 7-6 7-4 in relation to launched
and Paul had Lane I will now invite
officer to make a presentation in
relation to this application thank you
for planning consent is sought for the
demolition of the existing dwelling
known as Lewiston and its associated
garage and then the erection of three
detached six bedroom dwellings with
associated garages in its place the site
is located on Paul head lane with in the
area of time within Arden and is
indicated by the black dot this slide
shows the site and you more clearly
outlined in red and within the context
of the neighboring dwellings and also
indicates the visibility splays proposed
for the access to the site the site is
located within the green belt and the
Arden special landscape area this is a
google aerial image of the site the red
shape roughly outlining the existing
plot and the aerial view gives an
indication of the pattern of residential
development along pool head lane with
the golf course to the rear of the site
this current application follows a
recent outline approval on site granted
in February of last year the image on
your screen is an indicative layout plan
that was approved on for the previous
outline consent which sought to
subdivide the existing plot into three
plots retaining the existing dwelling in
the center and placing new dwellings
either side under this arrangement it
was judged that the scheme constituted
limited infill development in the
Greenbelt
and our search was considered acceptable
in principle the proposal before you
this evening is for the erection of
three dwellings on this site each
setback a similar distance from Paul
head Lane and set within a building plot
of similar shapes and
sizes the proposed for dwellings would
be of a contemporary design including
flat roofs there is a slight gradient to
the land across the site
the elevation details shown on the top
the top of the screen is of the street
scene as would be viewed from pool head
lane and the bottom is as viewed from
the rear the images show the proposed
dwellings within the context of the
neighboring properties so the heights
between the properties can be seen on
the screen now are more detailed
elevation drawings of proposed darlings
showing the proposed contemporary design
and flat roof details the design
includes discretely discretely located
photovoltaic excuse photovoltaic panels
and behind a parapet wall shown on this
in each of each of the units and the
scale of massing although there are
architectural differences between each
of the dwelling lists of the scalar
massing of each of the proposed Rawlins
is substantially similar to provide an
indication of how the darlings would
appear within the street scene the
applicant provided a cgi image here
showing the houses as a comparison I've
taken a Google image to the top of the
site from a similar location and just by
means of context this is the existing
dwelling and access to the site this is
a view looking towards the southwest a
long pool head lane with the back of the
person taking the photo to the access
and this is looking in the other
direction and this is a view from the
rear of the site Thank You chair there
are no updates and the recommendation is
to grant planning information registered
to speak is mr. Anthony Dixon on behalf
the Parish Council so if I could invite
you forward
no no we just deal with your all
submission thank you thank you though
mr. Dixon so mr. Dixon if I can just say
you're here to speak I understand for
three minutes on behalf of the Parish
Council and then three minutes
as a resident objector so what I'd like
you to do is address your comments that
are on behalf of the Parish Council so
we're very clear which part relates to
the parish councils opinion and then
which part relates to your views as
resident Lea yes yes that would be
perfect
thank you yes so what actually what I
would suggest perhaps is it's been
suggested to me I think it's a good idea
but after your three minutes on behalf
of the parish council we'll pause and
then any questions can be presented to
you in relation to comments and opinions
on behalf of the parish and then we can
move on to what you have to say is a
resident objector right we will start
timing you as soon as you start to speak
thank you good evening Council it's a
few years since I was last here I did
not expect to be as I considered this
application so far adrift from the local
vernacular that the planning team could
not possibly formulate such a
recommendation the Parish Council
objected to the previous application
which created plots on either side of
the residence but only by the demolition
of a garage in an annex I thought in
fill with the space between properties
not space created by demolition the
application seeks to maximize the
development of this Greenbelt site the
applicant states it is important that
the use of land resource is optimized
and goes on at 5.30 owing an appraisal
of the site optimization of the land use
land use it can more readily be achieved
if the existing house is demolished and
at five point six to meet these
objectives a new dwelling topology has
been developed that reverses the more
site hungry wide frontage shallow depth
building form to create a deeper plan
form a form which is specifically ruled
out in your own Stratford district
design guide on
age 50 if this was a one-for-one
replacement the total built volume would
be totally unacceptable in the greenbelt
the parish counselor does not consider
that there is a need to optimize that
land use within the Greenbelt what is
important is the retention of local
distinctiveness as outlined in policy
cs9 which opens with all forms of
development will improve the quality of
the public realm and enhance the sense
of place reflecting the character and
the distinctiveness of the locality to
understand the local distinctiveness I
quote from a report prepared in respect
to the NDP for the parish council the
authors of which have worked on world
heritage sites and have won our TPI
awards for excellence they describe
would end as follows would end is
basically loosed along broad Lane and a
series of rural lanes and roads running
perpendicular to it the small
residential settlement consists of
ribbon developments running along the
road and each of the lanes the most
extensive of which runs north along
bullhead Lane that report describes
would end as rural the report before you
describes Paul head Lane as suburban
opposite the proposed development is a
field with horses and stables there are
no pavement foot ways along any of the
lanes running off Broad Lane and there
are no streetlights
it is not suburban it is definitely
rural the description 30 seconds there
is low density of houses with properties
set back within deep spacious plots the
overall sense of spaciousness you've
seen the photos is a key characteristic
of the area Parish Council considers
this application fails to satisfy policy
cs9 and rather than enhancing the area
the introduction of flat-roofed
properties end on to the road
positively damages the street scene
these designs have been prepared to
optimize land use so much so that opaque
windows require time outside and facing
windows thank you time up committee any
questions
helps the barns probably about a mile
counselor okay counselor crumpled parish
council at this moment object is
obviously the ward member can speak for
himself
and indeed in conversation with him I
can cover that in my next speech forgive
me I've been told maybe the question is
no counselor Crump I think you gonna be
opportunity from counts right Kinnison
you've heard from camp mr. Dixon you'll
be able to compare the two opinions I
think I think that's the view other
questions for mr. Dixon next three
minutes yes Kasparov Kissin drew my
attention to a modern design approved
for the redevelopment of a property
about two miles from this site the
officers report reads the application
site is one of two residential dwellings
sited adjacent to each other outside of
the village of Tanith open countryside
surrounds these two properties as there
is no distinct street scene I considered
the introduction of a building of
innovative design to be appropriate
the recent refusal for development at
Highland on full-height Lane described
the street scene as characterized by
mainly open and spacious plots that
application was refused by the officers
because it was considered to harm the
street scene it is therefore evidence
that there is a street scene which could
be damaged a site visit by the committee
may be a best way forward this is your
district design guide when published it
was the winner of the RTP I West
Midlands regional award in
introduction it reads applicants for
planning permission must demonstrate
them in the material submitted that they
have given due consideration to the
issues and the principles set out in the
guide additionally to achieve the
objectives of this guide the central
focus is the distinctive local qualities
of the district new development should
share some of the characteristics that
define the area also in the introduction
it reads the application procedure
should demonstrate in text and graphics
that the design submitted shares a
sufficient number of those
characteristics or justify their absence
you may think this this design is out of
date this guide is after date being
published in 2001 but it is referred to
on page 33 of your reports under other
documents and policy cs9 replicates most
of the content councillor Atkinson
considers that architectural innovation
should not be stifled your design guide
paragraph 8 to 2 reads the predominant
forms within a settlement should be the
starting point or the reference for new
design and at eight point to sixth a
principal aim of design should be a
balance between innovation and local
character in my submission and that of
the many local residents who have
objected this proposal reflects very
little local character and the retention
of the mature oak trees along the
eastern boundary is the weakest attempt
as they act by the applicant to comply
with a strict signal as such this
application should be refused as it
fails to comply with policy cs9 30
minutes report for the outline planning
permission three minutes others tonight
in fact the officers report for the
outline permission included the
following I am satisfied that
appropriately designed dwellings in this
location would be acceptable appropriate
is the operative word there's no
increase in the number of properties for
the LVT essentially you've already got
permission for to the permission
included in is a requirement as to the
maximum height of 8.5 I live in port
head laying in the five bedroom property
was over three
time's finished now give me cutting you
off
any questions committee any further
questions
Oh
Dixon thank you thank you if I could now
invite to speak mr. Paul Watson agent
yes mr. Watson you have six minutes and
I will give you a 30-second warning well
thank you for that and thanks to you in
your committee for the opportunity to
speak but I don't think I'll detain you
for six minutes tonight I say that
because you have before you but in my
view is a thorough balanced and well
argued report from your offices it
addresses all of the issues raised by
the objectives in writing and by mr.
Dixon tonight so very little new ground
to cover that report concludes that the
report is limited in filling and so not
inappropriate in the greenbelt that the
proposed development would have no
detrimental impact on the wider
Greenbelt it wouldn't be harmful in
terms of highways in terms of
residential amenity or in any other way
and in fact in my view it would be a
positive addition to the street scene of
pool headline and its evolution over
time doesn't share the key components of
local distinctives in this area it's
actually we took retains and respects
them and that key component is its
substantial properties well back from
pool headline behind a line of mature
trees these are unashamedly contemporary
design it's good design it's by a
distinguished architect it's promoted by
a local developer both intent on
delivering for you a high-quality scheme
and I commend it to you in your
committee councillor Richards thank you
very much for that and your forgive me
if I get this wrong but I understand
your outline is for two
properties and yet you've come forward
with three what's the thinking behind
that the extant Planning Commission is
for the retention of the existing
building plus two so that's three in
total and this is this is three in
turtle understood thank you we've had no
direct discussions with the the parish
council on this matter we had a meeting
with a case officer in the case officer
was going to go back and talk about the
outcome of that meeting where we sought
to reassure him in terms of some other
points that have been made but I repeat
we've had no direct dialogue with the
parish council counselor bonds sorry if
I'm a counselor bonds I should say
pre-application we did speak to
neighbors on both sides of the property
I think that's the extant consent rather
than the proposed development that's the
pose any others no thank you person
thank you to committee have any
questions for officers oh sorry
council raccoons and how could I forget
you
I've espares anyway
chairman and members and officers I
think what's important to look at is the
National Planning policy framework and
they're in Section 59 it does tell us
that design policy should avoid
unnecessary prescription then it goes on
into 60 should not attempt to impose
architectural stars or particular tastes
and they should not stifle innovation
originality or initiative through
unsubstantiated requirements to confirm
to certain development forms of styles
the NPP F therefore is a key planning
consideration that is drawn out in the
offices report if one goes through the
agenda there are a number of comments
made which I believe support this
application they substantially indeed on
page 32 at the top the majority of
dwellings in the street scene are set
back from the road by a substantial
amount with long generally landscaped
front gardens parking and burning areas
there's also comments about each
building has individuality within this
street to see going into other pages
chairman there is comment of a similar
nature actually the proposed garages
would be set forward of the dwellings
but they would be low in height still
set back a significant distance from the
public highway and generally well
screened by existing and proposed of
vegetation as such the general openness
and that's the important point of the
domestic gods and man between the
proposed dwellings and the public
highway would be maintained
that's the officer's comments which I
certainly endorsed fully another one the
proposed dwellings would also be broadly
in line with the existing scale layout
and grain of development in the vicinity
so in principle is supported by the
provisions of CS 15 all so they proposed
scale and grain of the doora that
development would be broadly in line
with the widest street scene as such I
consider the proposed development to be
small-scale if one goes down cool head
lane there are more variations on a
theme of Paganini than one could ever
imagine and therefore I cannot quite
understand the objections which have
been raised yeah it also endorses on
page 38 there is little uniformity of
design along pool head Lane with some of
the modern development taken a similar
contemporary design approach which to me
indicates there's nothing unusual with
this application also on page 38 having
regard to neighboring buildings being
mostly conventional modern dwellings
with little uniformity in design scale
and Dremel form it is considered the
site in question is capable of
accommodating a contemporary design
approach chairman there are many other
factors in this officers report which
support the application and I don't see
any need to deviate from it what is
interesting of course in mr. Dixon's
comment is that he does say that I think
the expression is many residents object
to the application well we have got 22
registered objections the voters rule
will show there are 1058 electors on the
register that to me if my arithmetic is
correct means that there are less than
2% in objections to this application if
that is a measure of support for this
proposal then I don't think anything
else is let's say 98% are satisfied I
think chairman that is the appropriate
thing to get across to members Thank You
chairman for listen to me
Thank You council that concern time any
questions
councillor Crump just like to turn that
around a bit thousand people on the
register thousand fifty eight thousand
fifty eight on this it was missed in the
report I can't see any letters of
support from local residents perhaps
that's the point for clarification for
the officer so that's there just turn it
though I find devil's advocate there as
in elections chairman my interpretation
of that is the 98 percent of satisfied
yeah but I do find it quite surprising
obviously 22 it's quite a lot for yeah
some my application for my ward
you know 22 letters of support or
objection would be quite quite good so I
think to play the number down is perhaps
not quite fair and it's noticeable that
obviously the parish council who
represent the phase and and noranti I
2054 object to disaster I think to be
fair and be balanced I think might have
slightly over regular put in there I've
been quite fairly us but there's a
question okay why are you you said in
your five minutes that what you
supported it but you do seem to be a
going against the people who've taken
the time to write in and also the
council so you seem to be not in they're
not in the core why's that well chairman
we had in a area called Bates Lane a
similar application which was a
contemporary design the parish council
were against it
the officers recommended approval and it
was approved this I believe is a similar
situation I think that if residents of
Poole
I was so upset that more than 2% would
have responded I don't go along with the
analysis which my colleague has made it
does not represent what I term public
opinion counselor bombs well chairman
I've read a number of objections from
CPRA the only comfort I get from some of
their remarks is that planning is not an
exact science and I presume from that
that they recognize that is a situation
with some of their comments and
particularly in this instance more so
when you read and you understand what I
have addressed earlier about the
policies outlined in the NPP F don't
inhibit innovation I've seen thank you
note cancel it I think that is a full on
so on top of a very full submission and
we've had that point thank you and any
questions I knew the questions Thank You
counsel raccoons Thank You committee any
questions for the addresses I just have
one it seems as though a lot of the
issues surrounding the degree to which
this is in keeping with the character of
the area and under design and I just
wonder if you could provide some
guidance to committee about how they
should how they should consider that
question and what really the test is in
in terms of the balance to be stroked
something that we should put our own
tastes onto so we when we're looking at
consistency in character of the area we
look at things such as plot depth size
whether there's a general pattern of
development character of the grain so
the spacing between properties and
matters of enclosure and those kind of
things add to the character of an area
and that's how officers have assessed
this so things that just scale but the
heights of buildings in this locality
whilst these may be of a flat roof
design there are of a similar height to
the neighboring properties the
properties are set back within the plots
consistent with neighboring units so
it's those kind of characteristics in
terms of the local character to have
been taking into consideration yeah I
think the thing that was helpful from
Victoria and just just to add to those
elements of design which are considered
scale density massing height landscape
layout and the materials have all all
been looked at in detail within the
report I think in respective density of
the site we are mindful of the extant
outline permission members would have
seen in the presentation in respect of
scale and height the Street View which
elements of these buildings are capable
of falling below the height of
neighboring properties and so having
looked at those relationships with
neighboring properties and with the
surrounding area we come to the point of
considering whether our views are more
to do with the architecture or
particular styles and as councillor
Atkinson drew upon the NPP F points us
clearly that we should not attempt to
impose architectural styles or
particular tastes or to stifle
innovation and originality so I think
the case officer in this quality scheme
councillor Audrey is there any picture
you've got that can ship I'm just I'm
focusing on those garages are brought
forward sort of and they don't seem to
fit the street scene from the
neighboring properties are there any
other things you can point to where
something is built that close to the
main road I think if you if you look at
that plan you see that the existing
garage on lawn stand it's slightly
forward of the building line and there
are other properties further down poor
head which have outbuildings in front of
I understand from the officers report
that there are further buildings as well
which just so I can clarify that's
pretty helpful that picture in front of
the half a dozen buildings either side
there is possibly one you could argue
that has something built in just where
the ours has something built in front of
the houses so this would be a paid
change to the street scene certainly
we've been this slide only those that
there's the existing property that has a
garage to the front of it so that that
that is how this currently is configured
and then one three to the south of that
but yeah otherwise there are no other
examples on this slide but these look to
be further forward are you able to
roughly put an area where you think
good one
so my roughly I would say I would say
it's slightly forward of the existing
garage the Kings between the two with
the neighboring property being here the
garage finished here I would say on the
previous I was existing yes yep anything
else no ok pin the matter up for debate
absolute in' Thank You chairman having
looked to this my only real problem is
probably the three garages that council
of audrey has just brought up
however on balance I'm reading the
conclusions of the planning officer and
looking at the NPP f which the ward
member said it's not a contra to that
it's certainly not contrary to our
adopted core strategy so in that case
I'm more than happy to propose that we
accept this application in accordance
with the officers recommendations
councillor Richards I agree entirely
with my colleagues right and I would
second his proposal comes Laban's I've
had few applications in my village but
we haven't been it we haven't been
allowed to have the garages that far
away so we are in a commuter cycle can
beautif assistance to the railway okay
anyone else on that basis then we have a
proposal to grant the application from
councillor Lawton seconded by Councillor
councillor Richard so I'll take a vote
on that all those in favor of that
proposal to grant against
the application is granted and the
committee resolves to grant it thank you
yeah we'll just have a two-minute break
thank you
we will now proceed to do with
application 18 / 0 0 808 full Westbrook
Valley Road Earl's wood and I invite the
officer to make a presentation in
relation to the application Thank You
chair this application is the full
application for the erection of three
detached dwellings with garages the
application site lies close to the
center of Earls wood identified by the
black dot on the plan the site is
located to the rear of an existing
dwelling known as Westbrook and sits
between the properties to the west at
Earls Mayor and those to the east which
front shut lane the site is washed over
by the west midlands Greenbelt and the
front part of the site where the access
is located is within flood zone 3 the
rear part of the site where the proposed
dwellings are to be towed to be located
lies within flood zone 1 the site also
lies in the Arden special landscape area
this slide shows the extent of the flood
zones from the Environment Agency
website members will note the extent of
the blue shaded area which illustrates
flood zone 3 here we have the proposed
site plan which shows three detached
dwellings with associated garage in the
existing access from Valley Road will be
utilized and an access road created
through to the rear of Westbrook to the
three dwellings this plan shows the
elevations of plot 1 which via which
would be a five bedroom detached house
with attached double garage these are
the elevations of the dwelling proposed
at plot 2 which is a 4 bed detached
house with attached double garage and
these are the elevations of plot 3 which
again is a for bed detached house with
double garage
this slide shows the proposed site
section on the left are the existing
properties at URLs there and the right
shows the proposed dwellings we now have
some photos of the site and surroundings
here where stood on Valley Road looking
towards the access to the application
site which is annotated on the photo in
the foreground of the photo is the
access into Ellesmere which is an
existing cul-de-sac consisting of 11
dwellings we're now standing at the
other end of Valley Road with the
application site access on the right of
the photo and the lakes on the left
looking directly into the application
site the existing dwelling known as
Westbrook is to the right behind the
vegetation this access will be utilized
for the proposed developments this photo
is taken from the rear of the
application site and was taken back in
April 2017 when the previous application
on the site was being considered this
photo shows the land to be garden area
associated with Westbrook this photo was
taken in April this year and looks
towards the rear of the site where plots
2 & 3 would be located we're now looking
towards the properties at URLs near to
the east of the site I now have a video
to show
we're looking directly at Ellesmere and
now panning around the application site
towards where plot 3 would be located
and then plot 2 and finally around to
plot 1 and towards the neighboring
properties and then back towards the
property's URLs there there is one
update to the application referring to
two additional comments received chair
the recommendation is to grant the
application subject to the conditions
set out on pages 59 to 60 of the agenda
Thank You Eleanor if I could invite
councillor Cunningham on behalf of the
ton within arden parish council to speak
counselor as you've seen you've got
three minutes and I will give you a
30-second warning at the end the
building lights that you see I saved the
bureau but within the belt there are no
very special circumstances identified so
the presumption must be a development
SDC is on rationale from the imposition
of the view of is to distinguish
winters acceptable and principle from
land outside their poetry were subject
to certain exemptions development is not
acceptable settlement by trees there's
books that help prevent encroachment
into the countryside and this is
particularly important and became felt
the same document then goes on to define
the confines of the viewer included
within the confines of a settlement our
areas of residential cartilage and West
these areas that clearly paddles for
orchards our lands were appropriately
defined as annoying or beneath the land
dive aside the view out must therefore
be defined as non-urban with a
presumption against development the
granting of this application contravenes
SDC's or policy statements from the
rationale for applying buicks to errands
fees it is inappropriate and unnecessary
development of the Greenbelt that
affects the openness of the Greenbelt
countryside without demonstrating
special circumstance further FCC
planning policy resistant Lee asked by
email specifically about Greenville LS
be limited in full definition and
Matthew Neil responded by agreeing that
limited anything is to be applied as
follows
limited in scale a number of dwellings
fitted into a given linear gap limited
in terms of some applications being
granted and some not limited in terms of
the size of volumes the new buildings
proposed compared to surrounding
properties this plan therefore
contravenes SDC's or new policies on
Liberty then filled because it cannot
reasonably be construed as being fitting
fitting into a narrow gap only the
guarantees fit within this policy
finally there are flooding issues which
others will cover but thought they may
not know just know is that everything
that is heavy rain the sewers Beach the
manhole covers fogs up the hill and rush
to each place down through the
triple-s i and i met with water on this
problem two years ago 30 seconds Thank
You councillor Cunningham committee any
questions no it appears you're free to
go thank you I have next on the list for
objectors a mr. Robert Prince now mr.
Prince I understand you have provided
some photographs and video offices to be
played obviously you have three minutes
so were you content for those would you
like to indicate when you'd like them to
be played or are you content for them to
be played as you're speaking and you
will speak to them thank you madam chair
I think why don't I pour so if I just
give a two minute in two second in tow
I'm Robert Prince I've not been to a
planning committee before I've been a
resident of Ellesmere at 12 years and I
represent seven of my neighbors we live
as you saw from the map to the left or
west of the development and that is
significantly downhill of the
development of Westbrook and I wanted to
raise one point of the committee which
was that the flooding that we have
suffered since they saw it was cleared
at the end of January and so these
photos the first one so if you could
just go back was there water coming
through my back guards and on the 27th
this was not peak flow this was taken
when we were starting to get worried and
before we started running everything
upstairs
the next photos this is residence number
eight Pete Landers his his patio has
been uprooted by the force of the water
that came through that fence is the
fence with that borders with Westbrook
for mr. Landers you proceed with D this
is that residence number two which is
the opposite side of it was made to the
side that I live so I live
this is the opposite side and the force
of the water carried right across the
road and actually flooded the front of
residence number two you can't really
see but on the right is his front door
and to the water came up and over his
front door into his into his patio this
restaurant had been resident for 17
years has never been flooded this is the
the top of Valley Road where the lakes
are and I think that all you can really
see from this without zooming in is that
the water has come from behind so the
Westbrook development is to the the top
right hand corner of that photograph and
the water has has flowed from the top
right hand corner towards Valley Road
whenever we have suffered flooding
before in us and as marked on that map
with the flood zone 3 the water always
comes from the river Blythe and so it
would flood the front of the road there
which you see is valued rather than
flooding our residences so I would just
respectfully ask the committee if they
would be able to reconsider the current
planning application in terms of the
impact that the site clearance has had
today on our homes mr. Prince you still
what a minute would you like us to play
the two videos that you saw if you don't
mind this is residence number six so
this is this is two door two houses
further west of the development so is
this this waters passed through number
eight and number seven and there's
actually party now through the back
garden of number six what you can't see
is his whole garage was flooded and so
the water was coming out of his garage
into his home this is I believe
residence number seven and so what we
were just showing here was the water
coming around the house like an island
and I'm rushing down into the into the
into the the area called e sack so you
can see it this is a company that is
looking back towards westbrook's of
Westbrook would be up and to the the top
left of this at this video thank you
that's pretty much three minutes thank
you very much questions Laban's
surface area and increase the accounts I
saw work in healthcare I don't know
anything about about engineering or
surveying but all I can say is that
since their site was cleared I think you
saw they before and after photos the
site clearance at Westbrook has created
a threat for residents and if this was a
graphically I just have one question the
conditions that are proposed to be
attached if this application is granted
is that the applicant provides a full
plan really to deal with any flood
issues including drainage and so on and
so forth do you think that might be
something that could resolve and deal
with your concerns
quite possibly without seeing the detail
it would be difficult to comment but we
did raise objections to the of which the
the committee have considered I have no
no wish to go over those again but the
this I wanted we wanted to put forward
the fact that the situation has changed
since things were objected before and I
don't know how you would mitigate that
all I can explain is that our houses are
downhill of the proposed development and
that this is a very new problem in 17
years of residency for the for the
members that I represent that we've not
had a problem like this ever before
any other questions it's a great
question and it's difficult to comment
because um in terms of the year that we
had obviously we've had very heavy snow
but he thought very gradually the
gardens have been notably wet and so on
that if I was to point to that White
House is incorrectly labeled as number
10 but my neighborhood number 11 their
garden is almost permanently now under
water and they never they have a well
that was part of the original feature in
their backyard and then the water table
now is is that the level of the well and
I don't know if this is subsequent to
the development or not it will be
difficult to make an informed comment
that is the first time that we've been
flooded and the first time that we've
had water coming from this direction
any others no thank you very much thank
you if I could now invite the agent
Laura Paul to speak
miss mr. Hussey with you who is not
planning to speak to us and but it's
just here to answer any questions the
committee may have afterwards so you
have six minutes and I'll give you a
30-second warning yes and thank you for
the opportunity to address your
committee tonight the scheme now in
front of you is the result of
discussions with the Kansas planning
officer and has obviously a
recommendation for approval the very
thorough and detailed committee report
clearly explains that the proposal is
entirely compliant with relevant
planning policies and in particular the
policies on housing and Greenbelt of the
adopted core strategy and also on the
council's guidance on assessing impact
on neighboring amenities the offices and
statutory consult EES have no objection
to the scheme the principle of the
development was already accepted with
the previous application for the site in
2017 and this concludes that the side
lies within the built of area boundary
of else would the offices report
confirms that the emerging site
allocations plan can only be given very
limited weight and that a detailed
assessment was undertaken as part of
this application and of the previous
application but officers confirming that
the site's location within the build a
barrier boundary of worlds would the
property Westbrook is clearly lies
within the confines of the settlement
and the application side is part of the
residential curtilage and this is one of
the criteria to assess whether a side
lies within the built of barrier
boundary as you know I know it comments
on the application that the site would
not be classified as limited infill
however the term is not clearly defined
and needs to be considered as a matter
of fact in degree the site is clearly
appropriate as a limited infill side
which was assessed and confirmed in the
committee report by the planning officer
in this and also in the previous
planning application as part of the
adopted core strategy policy CS 16
housing development the council
indicates that of the 450 new homes to
be located within category three
villages
no more than 13 percent should be within
it one individual settlement this
equates to 59 dwellings and as assessed
within the committee report the
application scheme would take the number
of neutral links and also hood up to six
dwellings which is clearly well below
the maximum number 59 and the site is
clearly in in one of the most
sustainable and accessible locations
within the village of Earls would with
regard to any potential flooding concern
I would like to reaffirm that the
application is supported by a flood risk
assessment and also the environment and
the Environment Agency also did not
object to the scheme the report comes to
the conclusion that the proposed
development is entirely appropriate to
the flood risk and it is not expected to
increase the risk of flooding elsewhere
in respect of storm drainage this can be
appropriately dealt with by a planning
condition which would help to address
recent flooding issues experienced the
neighbours and what was just mentioned
so this would improve the situation on
the site the concerns raised with the
previous application in respect of over
shadowing from existing trees and
possible concerns will noise concerns
will addressed as part of this scheme
and as the offices report confirms the
proposal is now acceptable as you will
be aware in addition none of the other
statutory consult EES have objections to
the scheme including ecology Natural
England and environmental health I
acknowledge the neighbours concerns but
based on the planning merits of this
scheme there's clearly no objection
against this residential development
that is well considered sustainably
located and has been thoroughly assessed
to have no impact on any neighbouring
immunities the committee reports
provides a detailed assessment on the
potential impact of any neighboring
properties and is satisfied that there
would be no exists no impact on any
existing or future residents and the
site can appropriately accommodate the
three dwellings without ever developing
the site the houses will have well
proportioned rear gardens and off street
parking for residents and visitors and
in respect of this the highway authority
also is not objecting to the scheme in
summary I would like to reaffirm the
proposal accords with all relevant
planning policies of your adopted core
strategy and also supplementary guidance
you obviously support the proposal and
confirms its compliance with the
development plan and therefore I will
hope you support this application thank
you very much councillors any questions
councillor Barnes obviously the drainage
will be conditioned but as part of the
proposal we proposing permeable surfaces
and also attenuation storage any other
questions thank you very much yes free
to go councillor Atkinson
chairman members when the opinion from
the Environment Agency was given who was
day to the first of May the issues which
were highlighted by my resident occurred
on the 27th of May and I don't think
they can be ignored
there are many implications they're not
just from our own point of view but just
think of the insurance factor of their
houses being subject to flooding and
what that may mean in order to get
adequate cover
however in planning terms we must look
upon it in that way I really do not
believe we can go forward with this
application without a thorough appraisal
of what what the flooding risk factors
are if as I did this last week went
around and saw what had occurred
I assure that blocks of paving had been
uplifted there was sand around which in
a way looked like some of the residents
in Whitley Bay which is an area know
pretty well it is absolute nonsense to
think we could pass an application at
this stage without adequate information
about the flood risks which exist they
are there whether they've been created
by the removal of the trees I am not
qualified to comment about what is
needed however is a full appraisal to
ensure that we have some idea of what
the risks are because I don't know in
legal terms but if this application was
granted without that assurance what
remedial claim residents would have upon
our authority unless alone others I am
NOT certain about but I would say there
is a risk factor
they're without any doubt I believe this
application chairman should be deferred
until such time as we have a fundamental
and full appraisal of the flood risks
which have been proven with this
particular area
don't forget the residents who have been
represented here tonight have lived
there for 17 19 20 years and have never
had such a problem until the site was
modified for one reason or another I
believe chairman your members would be
foolhardy in granting application
without the caution of making certain
flood issues are addressed and my
suggestion is that you defer it in order
to get that information so that at least
if you agree to grant you can agree it
in confidence otherwise I think you may
have a contingent liability on your
hands Thank You chairman for listening
the Environment Agency has been
consulted a flood risk assessment has
been completed and there isn't objection
from that statutory agency you've also
heard the applicant outline that there
will be a proposal for a sustainable
drainage scheme and obviously measures
in place to try to deal with the current
surface water that's there and I just
wondered
in what way you felt that perhaps didn't
satisfy matters the Environment Agency
opinion was I believe given on the 1st
of May the problems arose on the 27th I
can understand the applicant wanting to
give assurance of way but I naturally
believe an independent view away from
the request who grunt is necessary so
that an adequate appraisal can be
determined I think I'm right the
Environment Agency opinion was the 1st
of May this problem arose
nearly four weeks afterwards whether
it's the trees or being removed I don't
know that's not my scene in life we need
as an authority to be assured that if
you want to grant a permission yeah you
have constant valuable information Thank
You committee any other questions for
counsel Atkinson no thank you very much
committee I invite you to ask any
questions of officers councillor Norton
Thank You chairman chaps hair lady sorry
um Ellen uh good evening okay there is a
big problem here with flooding I've read
in your report
my technical question is could we if we
minded to grant this application
condition it that appropriate
attenuation tanks for a benefit of
members that is underground storage of
of water in a storm can become a
condition to do what would be a standard
a term to to cope with a 30-year flood
risk so there would be a 1 in 30 year
risk of a flood is that possible
certainly a condition that went down the
lines of requiring this site to restrict
drainage to Greenfield rates and with a
calculation done to demonstrate that it
can hold water in the event of a flood
event plus climate change has been done
is appropriate and could be implemented
on this so the answer is yes we could
condition it yes
okay fine thank you it's live Audrey
politely challenge that decision without
an evidence base on the reasons for the
flooding wouldn't that condition much I
think it would be a right condition but
couldn't it not be subsequently
challenged unless we have further
evidence to say it's really required it
could be seen as being too you know too
extreme and so it ties back in with
council actions point about I presume
there is no evidence do we need some
form of mordy
I'll report to be attached to whether
that condition can be sustained but it
feels like it's it's going the right way
for that conditions ya know I welcome
the comment I think to clarify what we
would be asking for in the edition would
be something that requires the applicant
to restrict one-off rates to those which
were equivalent to the existing use the
Greenfield rate as it exists now so
we're not asking them for measures over
and above to compensate for the impact
of development elsewhere it would be to
offset what they're doing on their own
site okay just so I'm clear then it
might not be to the extent of the castle
Lawton was asking for unless there was
evidence based to kind of justify that
that level of those underground things
they would be consuming their own smoke
I think it's probably the best way to
describe it they they would not be
compensating for other other issues that
may be can I ask
obviously you heard councillor Atkinson
say that the work of the Environment
Agency took place before this event took
place on the 27th of May is there any
merit in them having or there being
further consideration given to the
evidence that's been provided by
residents and that what would appear to
be potentially new information I think
that the flood risk assessment provide
assessment we have imposed conditions in
similar circumstances in the past a
standard approach to secure the
engineering of drainage via condition
and I think it's appropriate in this
dance to do so with the knowledge of
what's been put before us as well our
proposed development would have to
ensure that appropriate drainage is put
in place and would help to address the
recent flooding issues that have been
experienced by our neighboring
properties this two-part question was
how would the development ensure the
appropriate drainage was put in place so
whatever did intersection would be put
in place and again are we saying that
the recent flooding issues were caused
by the development or the cutting down
on the trees or could it be something
else
this caused that flooding and therefore
aren't we putting in I think a known
risk potentially onerous condition to
try and resolve a problem that's not
being actually caused by this
development and in regards to the
condition looking at the surface water
runoff I spoken with my colleagues and
Building Control this morning and they
would look at any details put forward as
part of that condition if there were
attenuation tanks or whatever they were
proposing to deal with the surface water
runoff and they would have to be
satisfied that that dealt with the
surface water runoff as part of that
development and in regards the second
part of your question I can't be sure as
an officer what has resulted in this
recent flooding of the neighboring
properties I don't know if it was a
result of weather conditions there being
an unprecedented amount of rain over a
long period of time that resulted in
saturation of the neighboring land or if
it was to do with the felling of the
trees and the applications light and I
couldn't confirm what has caused this
recent flooding
Council of all dream we should be
excited as a planning application
flooding shouldn't be the only issue we
address so just for clarification from
for my benefit we've had the discussion
about is infill backfill appropriate in
you know in the Greenbelt as officers
you're you're entirely comfortable this
fits within all our policies for
actually building on this plot of land
that exists there whether it be backfill
info
yes that's correct so the report and
goes through the principle of the
developments in terms of its location
and the report acknowledges that in the
draft that was a parry boundaries the
site is excluded from the drawn draft
there was a parry boundary however and
at an officer level and having conducted
a site visit it's apparent that this
land is garden land associated with
Westbrook is residential curtilage and
when defining the settlement boundaries
and the document that we use an x3 the
old local plan does refer to land
included within the confines of
assessment areas of residential
curtilage and it's considered that this
is residential curtilage so
notwithstanding the draft there was a
peri boundary which has limited weight
it is not adopted
it's just been through the consultation
process and our policy team are
considering the responses on that the
site is considered to be within the
physical confines of the village council
abarnes yes the implication from one of
the speaker's was it was the rhythm
connected with this
I do have a slide which say and this
slide here blue you can see the river
Blythe which is a triple si and natural
England have been consulted on the
application and they are happy with the
proposal subject to conditions requiring
construction management committee any
further questions committee I'd like to
open mass up for debate and light
commenced and I'd like to say that I am
concerned that we've been given evidence
of what are clearly significant issues
in relation to flooding and I'm
concerned that we're told that those
issues have arisen since the Environment
Agency originally looked at them and
indeed we're all kind of slightly in the
dark about the specifics of the surface
water drainage scheme and whether that
will and satisfy the concerns that have
been raised and so I just wanted
committee to consider because it is an
option for committee to say the matter
can be deferred and we look for a more
detailed report which has considered the
specific evidence that has been put
forward around those flooding issues if
those are ever concerned committee
counsel Norton Thank You chair okay can
I just deal with the two points the
first of all is the principle the
development itself I'm completely on
board with this development I do think
it's infill if it was outside the boa be
I would have some serious concerns it's
a genuine infill it does comply with our
core strategy he complies with MPP F so
I don't think we've got any problem with
that okay let's talk about this issue of
drainage well the first thing I'd like
to say members is that if we do nothing
it's still going to flood there was an
opportunity to hear via development to
actually improve the situation for
neighbors now I know the concern
but as you know I have some expertise in
this area I've built four or five
developments in my time where we have
built very very big attenuation tanks
and that does there are calculations
that are way above my pay grade but so
that civil engineers can design drainage
systems to stop flooding in an
anticipated 30-year period and this is
why I ask the question where it could be
conditioned so on the basis that I'm not
quite 100% happy about deferring it
because I'm not quite sure that whether
a very very technical report came back
would would actually help us along I
think this is an civil engineering thing
it's probably not a planning thing but
it's can be conditioned by planning so
on that basis and if I can find a
seconder
I'm quite happy to propose that we
accept this application in in the form
that it is but subject to that the
subject to the planning officers and the
building inspectors and the civil
engineers coming up with his 30-year
flood alleviation scheme for an
attenuation tank on the site before it
come to council Richard can I just ask
committee to consider in what light of
what you said in many ways I agree with
it and I certainly agree is what you're
saying about the principles of
development but I think one
consideration is if we're going to get
the conditions right and make sure we
strike the right balance between being
onerous and appropriate to protect
people potentially the further
information could assist us with that
decision
but I'm will continue debate councillor
Richards thank you chair I again find
myself in agreement with councillor
Lawton and the principal gentlemen I
have absolutely no problem with
evidently there is a major concern of
the flooding it is flood risk level one
so that shouldn't really come as a huge
surprise to us this condition has been
put in place the details of famine
surface water drainage has been put in
place for a very good reason and I do
believe we'll address the issue clearly
no development can take place until that
has been satisfied that will come that
the details of that will come to our
officers for them to either approve or
reject I am aware of an application in
my own ward where we have a similar
issue that drainage scheme was put
forward and officers did reject it
because it was not sufficient and not
appropriate so all of the detail in the
appropriate work will come forward and
if it's not appropriate if it's not
relevant then it will be rejected if it
is it will be approved so I'm entirely
comfortable to go ahead and grant one
second what counsel already said anyone
else we have a seconded which is to a
grant application 18 / 0 0 8 8 / full
but just before I go to it I just wanted
to ask officers a question would it be
possible that if committee are minded to
grant this application that note could
be and I don't know whether you think
it's relevant or necessary but a note
could be go alongside it to suggest that
the evidence that's been presented to us
tonight in relation to the problems are
specifically transmitted to the those
dealing with the the surface water
drainage scheme and that protection
schemes that they are fully aware of
those issues and they are aware that
those need to be taken into account when
they are considering the scheme yes
would be appropriate drawing the
applicants attention to what is required
from the condition drainage in relation
to the condition and actually then the
note doesn't pertain to the applicant it
pertains really with what this committee
should do with the information it's got
that was the only reason I will be happy
with yes I am but just for clarification
so we all know we are voting if we do to
approve this subject to that attenuation
tank on a 30 year flood risk and office
well our officers opinion on that and
whether they think that is
reasonable condition in the manner in
which you've expressed is a standard
engineering term in a similar capacity
to that's above my paygrade to say
whether a thirty-year tank is the most
appropriate tank
I would accept your view on that my
inclination is to draft a condition
which should be agreed with the chair
once we have some technical input in
respect of those details I mean I think
you will find that the 30-year term is
pretty standard
I've just finished one last year and
Coventry I'm happy officer suggestion
because obviously that will come too
it'll either be myself but probably
counts a carriage and we can I can
inform him about what's been discussed
what committee considers an appropriate
award member please yes board member
very good idea yes okay committee so we
have a proposal to grant application 18
stroke 0-0 808 full all those in favor
all those against any abstentions this
committee proposes to grant resolves to
grant that application we'll just take a
short two-minute break
and then you can see yes I mean usually
have County highways and they object and
we go games that yes there was a duty of
care owed by us but environment agency
of course said no I have never new
information
David could be send that information to
them from ABC anyone have an impact on
the condition of innocence
you saw the picture and then some
decimation is like something thrown upon
in there
okay we are going to recommence we're
now dealing with application 17 / 0 3 4
1 7 4 paradise logic tinker's farm and I
write the office to present the
application Thank You chair planning
consent is sought for tip sorry
planning consent is sought to subdivide
the existing plot known as tinker's farm
cottage into two residential plots the
existing plot contains a main dwelling
house and an annex to this dwelling with
associated curtilage the site access is
from Stratford Road and is approximately
1.5 kilometers from Hockley heath as
indicated by the black dot this is the
redline boundary of the site which shows
the planning units ought to be created
by the application the site is located
in the open countryside in a special
landscape area and within the Greenbelt
this is an aerial photo of the site the
annex building is the building you can
see at the centre and this building here
with the main dwelling below this one
here the applicant states that since
2017 the annex has been known as
Paradise Lodge
this aerial photo has been marked up to
show the approximate boundaries to give
a clearer indication of how the site
would be subdivided from the information
submitted by the applicant and from our
own records it appears as though the
annex was converted from a garage
building and around 2006 the annex was
then occupied by a family member of the
tinkers family cottage on an ancillary
basis to the main dwelling these are the
existing plans submitted with the
applications shown the elevations an
internal layout of the annex no
alterations are proposed as part of this
application
these photos are off the site showing
the existing frontage of the annex in
the top left the annex and rear
curtilage in the top right and the
boundary to the site from the Stratford
Road at the bottom the photo in the top
left shows the existing dwelling main
dwelling house the photo in the top
right shows the annex as viewed from the
separate access and the bottom shows
that that access to the site there are
no updates chair and the proposal so the
recommendation is for refusal we don't
have anyone listed to speak on behalf of
parish council or any object is so if I
could invite the agent Donna Savage to
the front speak
mr. savage you have three minutes will
time it from when you start speaking and
I'll give you a 30-second warning Thank
You chairman for allowing me to address
the committee this evening and this
application is for the change of use of
an annex to a separate dwelling and
there are no physical alterations
proposed to either building or the site
and the site already has a separate
access it already has a separate parking
area and it has a separate residential
curtilage separated from the main
dwelling by and both a two meter high
fence and a hedge there are no there's
no harm caused by this proposal apart
from one matter which is whether this is
in a sustainable location or not the
reason for refusal states that the
dwelling would not be readily accessible
to shops primary schools employment
facilities and were not of good
connections to public transport and
therefore would be primarily dependent
on the car taking each in turn I'd like
to just add a few comments in terms of
primary school this is a small
one-bedroom dwelling and it is highly
unlikely that any children will occupy
the property my client herself is a lady
of a certain age and lives alone in any
event the nearest primary school is 1.5
kilometers away in terms of shops and
employment opportunities the site lies
1.5 kilometers from the center of hotly
heath which is several shops including a
post office it also has several
restaurants pubs and a hotel there are
also other businesses which provide
employment opportunities all of which
can be reached by a well-lit footpath
which extends from the site right to the
center of the village and beyond with
regard to connections to public
transport the site lies on the main
Stratford Road and is served by the x20
from Stratford to Birmingham providing a
regular service throughout the day and
the
to the evening the bus stop is just over
400 meters away again accessed by a well
lit footpath I therefore struggle to see
hi this is not a well-connected sight to
both shops employment primary school and
public transport I myself live within
the built-up area bindery of Stratford
and I would have to walk a similar
distance to reach those kind of services
and yet I'm deemed to live in a in a
sustainable location there is a recent
appeal decision which was he might in
March of this year
which is a very similar situation and
annex changing to a separate unit and
where the inspector concluded that it
was in relatively close proximity to
shops etc but using a car didn't
actually matter that much and in fact he
actually said so too so because es 15
and a s 10 did not require travel to be
made by other means contract concerns
it's going to take you into more detail
on that appeal decision so I'll stop
there
what I have to say I think the well-lit
footpath the distance to the shops and
services etc and the bus stop I believe
this is in the sustainable location I'm
gonna ask you to approve the application
thank you thank you Miss Savage
councillors any questions
that's the bonds the bus stops right
outside the royal oak it's not as
frequent as every 20 minutes because it
starts off being quite frequent then
there's periods of the day where it goes
to once an hour then it's geez up again
so it's it's not consistent throughout
the day but you could get a bus at any
time of the day from 7 o'clock in the
morning I think through to 10 o'clock at
night and any other questions thank you
mr. Burrage answer at concern
hey chairman thanks for the opportunity
to address you again on the application
could I just have the oh that's it
yes could the officer tell me what the
roundabout is there I hope this isn't
coming out of my time actually on the
yeah
what is the roundabout the m14 it is
part of the m-40 no that's that's the
roundabout to Hockley he d'Artagnan
Arden it is an access route to the
energy what I'm driving at you know is
an unsustainable location within the
open countryside
you've got the m-40 next door you've
also got 14 voters on the same register
with the same postcode there is built
form there so it is not an isolated
situation or location it not only that
but it is on a bus route which is not
mentioned here and it's 400 meters to
the walk to the bus which will take you
to both Birmingham and Stratford now
what I want committee to bear in mind is
an appeal decision which was February
this year
Greg goose cottage London Road Castleton
and some of the comments the building
could be occupied by an independent
adult family member without the need for
planning permission in that circumstance
there would be a negative bill
difference in the pattern of use of the
accommodation in comparison to its
occupation by a non-relative
consequently the conflict with the aims
of policy cs50 in an s10 would be
negligible furthermore the proposal
would provide a new small standalone
residential unit that would make a
contribution
albeit a modest one to the availability
of this type of housing in the district
that I think is a very fundamental
comment by a planning inspector about
the use
of the change in this application it
also goes on I accept that the appeal
site is somewhat remote from shops and
services and that its occupant would be
heavily reliant on the use of private
motorized transport for day-to-day needs
however there is nothing in CS policies
CS 15 or a s 10 that explicitly requires
travel to be made by other means and the
likely number of trips that would be
generated as a route of grant grant
admission would be very modest
commensurate with the occupation of a
small one-bedroom dwelling furthermore
there is a bus stop within 400 meters of
the site providing a link between this
is Morton and marsh and trip in Norton
exactly as we have got here
apart from the fact instead of Morton
and Marshall trip in Morton it is
Birmingham and stratford-on-avon
you have got within easy access Henley
and Arden
with a railway station which will give
you access throughout the country even
though you may have to change in
Birmingham and I tend to believe
chairman that with this appeal decision
if the applicant went to appeal then it
would be upheld because it matches the
terms which the inspector has an
illustrated and there's a particular
appeal there are others which I could
quote but I think that is quite
fundamental in assessing this
application which I believe has not been
assessed in the correct manner and I
hope members will therefore reverse it
and grant permission thank you Thank You
counsel Atkinson any questions
councillor bombs the Henry railway
station is circa about three kilometers
away three to four I get that I think
something comes out and reports
somewhere about it but it's not
impossible and you can park your car
there all day you can even walk there I
have
yeah thank you the other questions it's
like concern committee there is the
opportunity for technical questions I
would just like to ask one arising out
of councillor Atkinson councillor
Atkinson's obviously refer to this
appeal decision and I just wanted and he
he expressed the view that were we to
refuse this it would potentially be
appealable in his view and I just wanted
a cop officers had any comment on that
decision in those comments to say all
planning refusals are appealable I think
there are probably a couple of key
differences in respect of the histories
of the sites referred to which would be
material every application has to be
judged on its merits but it's relevant
to say that the background to this site
is one where and the enforcement
investigation found that the building
was occupied by a family member but at
that time it was not pursued and so it
has existed in a state being ancillary
residential annex to the self-contained
dwelling but without the Planning
Commission established I think that
would prove to be relevant in that
context councillor Barnes
if we were to approve this application
we'll really conditions to make sure it
wasn't built because it does appear that
it's the same building if you understand
me we could attach conditions we could
still attach conditions obviously there
is a building there but we might like to
consider other issues such as removal of
permitted development rights and things
that will make this an independent unit
any further technical questions I open
it up to debate
absolu Lauren Thank You chair okay where
I'm coming from here is there is no
Greenbelt issue whatsoever and I think
the report says that this is purely
whether this is a sustainable position
or not now members of this committee
will remember and two months ago that we
had a very similar application for a
conversion from holiday homes to normal
houses in wooden one in what is
considerably a less sustainable position
this aisle drove past the site today the
x20 goes every twenty minutes you can
walk to the oak in two minutes you can
walk to Hockley heath in ten I cannot
with for the life of me see why this is
not a sustainable location so in this
case I would put forward a proposal that
we go against the officers
recommendation because I agree with the
ward member and if this went to appeal
we wouldn't have a chance of winning and
that's probably not a planning reason
but the planning reason is that this is
demonstrably a sustainable position
councillor bombs but the 20-minute bus
service is not gonna get any less
because it's not in a rural area she's
in my eyes in a sustainable situation
and what bedroom houses happy to
secondly with the condition that I said
about no more development councillor
Richard once can I find myself in
complete agreement with councillor
Lawton
had intended ii s but obviously that's
already been done the fact is we've got
an annex that someone could live in now
regardless of whether they obviously
have to be part of the family or part of
who ever lifted the the building to
which is observing to but someone could
live there all we're doing is allowing
that to be separate and someone to
actually live there permanently I seen
little to no difference in allowing
someone to do that and actually it is
very much sustainable it's a short walk
to hopefully Heath it's a short walk to
hemming Arden myself an agreement but
also added even if it wasn't a short
walk it's extraordinarily short drive
with a motorway next to it and for us to
define this as an unsustainable
development when the motorway is right
there and you're going to drive straight
onto it people use cars so that there is
a substantial to almost hurt people
because they might jump into their car I
can't accept that particularly when
you're so near to a major a major road
network so I just con except I'm afraid
so I will be back before take a vote on
that I'm just going to consult offices
about conditions and reasons I just want
to just make a factual correction I
don't you can access the m-40 I
understand the principle of what you're
saying I don't necessarily disagree I
don't if you can access the m-40
together onto the motor where you can
come off there I think my son corrected
okay thank you
so if I could just invite officers if
committee and minded to grant the
application first I wonder if you could
give us a summary of the reasons that
that they have given for grant and also
secondly address any conditions that you
think need to be touched or a manner in
which we can deal with conditions
yep so in sorry what I've heard from the
debate is that in councillors views the
location is sustainable that the
proposed use is indivisible in some ways
from the existing use which is not being
enforced against that there are accesses
to services and therefore
notwithstanding the position are
identified in CS 15 this development
could be considered sustainable in
accordance with CS 1 sorry
moving on to conditions I think it would
be appropriate for the development to be
implemented within three years or
brought into its new use within three
years we would propose a PD rights
removal given that the curtilage of the
dwelling is likely to be quite
constrained development in accordance
with the plans as councillor bouncies
request to ensure that alterations and
then a condition which defined the
curtilage would seem appropriate given
that there is a an extended demise which
the red line identifies way and we would
expect the curtilage to lie councillor
bombs so again would like a water being
would that be an appropriate condition
we often apply a condition requiring
water pots and standard conditions
relating to water books bins and
electric vehicle charging points
council not a new happy for those to be
and it was your proposal absolutely
ecstatic J thank you um committee
therefore there is a proposal to grunt
application 1703 for one seven stroke
full all those in favor
all those sorry
all those against thank you
this committee therefore results to
grant that application no final
application yeah and I say I didn't
Claire to the start but actually I
thought this one was on but because I
think what a lot of people almost
opposite that side and I think I'm gonna
be better off to stepping down for this
one
Audrey
right counselors we deal with
application 1801 197 stroke adv Rayford
karen caravan park and i invite the
office to make a presentation
the application novel for members is for
the erection of a composite alloy sign
sign on didn't enroll at the entrance of
Rayford caravan park this application is
part retrospective as the sign has
already been erected the application
also includes a strip lighting strip
with a hood which has not yet been added
the application site identified here by
the black dots is situated on tootington
Road to the northeast of
stratford-on-avon here the application
site can be seen in the center of the
slide edged in black opposite the Street
of residential dwelling houses this
slide shows the application site Ejim
edged in red the yellow indicates the
site of a recent appeal decision for a
similar design of sign with identical
lighting for neighboring Riverside
caravan park this appeal is a material
consideration for the current
application this plans shows the
position on the right hand side of the
access road for the caravan park these
elevations so the design of the sign on
the lighting hood it be 3.5 meters in
total height and 8.1 point eight meters
in width and it be double-sided here are
some photographs of the sign and its
context as you can see the Sun has been
erected but the Lighting's not yet been
added here is the site as viewed looking
down tootington Road toward Stratford
and here facing the opposite direction
away from Stratford here are some
photographs showing the properties
directly opposite the sign and here for
comparison is the sign and lighting
approved at the appeal in 2015 at
Riverside caravan park as you can see
the lighting design is the same there
the appeal sign is actually a nought
point four meters taller than the
application sign chair the
recommendation is to grant and there is
one update on the update sheet in
respect to a comment received this
afternoon thank you very much yes
just so I'm clear this what we're
looking at now that was granted as
appeal is that right yes we refused it
and it was a thanks we don't have anyone
to speak on behalf of the town council
or objector so if I could invite mr.
Allen on the applicant to speak
mr. Allen you have three minutes and I
will give you a 30-second warning Thank
You Jay thank the opportunity to speak
to her and come to st. Clair myself may
I just make one very quick point at the
start the application that you just
spoken about about the other sign of
appeal that's incorrect information the
sign got approved by staff or district
council it was the lighting that had to
go to appeal
so the sign was approved under delegated
powers is a lighting bit as he wouldn't
appeal on that I managed the three parks
in Safra pont-aven so we've got a van
parked
rafer Park and Riverside Park the three
sites each have a single point of access
off the public roads
the ward vote entrance to Avon Park and
the tintin Road entrances for Riverside
each have consent for similar
illuminated signs other pops to listen
to both have illuminated signs ETV nfu
mutual building as well with quite a
busy sites there's a hundred and
eighty-seven caravans and lodges on
Rayford Park we have over 80,000
visitors each year and we give a fair
bit amount to tour them into the
Interceptor just accounts ourselves it's
why our guests need to find us out way
for Park and it is the only access off
the road for the actual park the stretch
it seems remote is located and built-up
area boundary of Stratford thus it is
not a conscious on location as stated
and the road has street lighting so
illuminated sign is not out of character
in that area thank you for time Thank
You committee any questions no mr. Allen
thank you if I can invite councillor
Rolf to speak
Thank You committee the reason I'm
talking to you this evening is because
restaurants living around this sign of
great concern regarding its suitability
sign further down which already has
permission retrospectively and through
appeal has less impact on the horizon
and Vista of the kidding term wrote than
this sign which is already in place and
again requiring planning retrospectively
the sign with permission is not seen
into oh you are round twenty-five yards
away as it is on a bend this current
sign you can see for around 300 yards
either side and it is on a straight run
of road and completely dominates the
view the sign is an advertising sign and
not directional and I believe because of
its sheer size is a distraction to
drivers this sign is too prominent as in
it and is in an area of restraint and
therefore contravenes policy CS 13 and I
quote land designated as an area of
restraint makes an important
contribution to the character of the
settlement development must not harm or
threaten the open nature of such areas
taking into account any possible
cumulative effects projects which
enhance the character and visual amenity
of areas of restraint will be encouraged
this does not enhance the character at
or detracts and swirls the visual
amenity of a semi-rural Road the
original sign was perfectly adequate and
served its purpose for many years it is
not necessary to have such an
overpowering sized sign the speed limit
along this road is 30 miles an hour and
not 40
as stated in the report as the speed is
that low there is plenty of time to see
a smaller and more in keeping sign it
doesn't have to be that big and it
doesn't have to be lit for a great part
of the year the trees are without leaves
and therefore the sign could be made
smaller and in any event if the sign
were smaller and lowered on the pole
people would still see it all year round
people have Sat Navs in their vehicles
they don't need to see such huge
advertising signs
the sign will also have an adverse
impact on residents on the hitting to
motors the light from it will be seen a
long and long stretch of road
I would also question whether it has
been put on private learned I believe
this would need to be checked before you
discuss this application if you look at
the picture there it will need to be
checked to see whether it's on County
highways land so maybe a site visit
would need to be carried out and Land
Registry looked into just because an
inspector has approved the previous sign
it doesn't mean that you should allow
this one as it's very different I would
urge you to ask the applicant to come
back with a more appropriately sized
unlit sign and refuse this one before
you thank you Thank You councillor oaf
councillor Richards Thank You councillor
off the last thing he said there was
that this sign is very different from
the other one in what way is it very
different it's different because it's on
a very very long stretch of road and you
see it this is on a bend that one is
unavailable yeah well no but the other
one you can see much further away much
much further away about 300 yards away I
decide the other one is on a slight bend
you don't see it it kind of comes upon
you any other questions
counsel Norton yeah just councillor
could you is that stretch of tilling to
Road is that got street lamps thank you
I just they're very low level low dimmed
street lights right can think you'd have
to ask mr. Allen he runs the caravan
park not me
thank you if you don't my dream and you
get strangers approaching well that's a
comment the other two were factual
questions and I was happy with them any
further questions for councillor Rolf
councillor Barnes it's very it's very
dominant councillor bonds is it a
question I think that's it counts are
all thank you very much any technical
questions
[Music]
the pipe from ground to base is 1.3
meters the sign itself is 2.2 meters in
height and 1.8 meters in width with the
depth of 9.2 meters and since it was
raised by counsel Ross she obviously
raised its sighting and whether the land
is in the ownership issue the counsel
Akram sorry counselor off said it was 30
miles an hour in the report it says the
road is subject to 30 mile an hour speed
limits just a point of clarification
just a point of clarification section to
clarify points that you're not sure
about and therefore I think the point in
case the ralph was trying to make was
that the slower you go it's easier to
see the sign whereas if you're doing 40
mile an hour depending what perspective
you look at and how close you are to the
camera it's difficult to see its
Watkinson yeah chairman what impresses
me actually there are six days of
objection take off the one letter of
support you've got five spread over in
the immediate area 17 dwellings which
must have more than one individual I
can't see any problem so therefore I
recommend approval counts Watkins and
we're still on technical questions but
okay right we'll move to debate I think
I'll second that fine okay I'd like to
offer anyone else the opportunity to
speak
Denis with my second name I hadn't so
sign up the road
I used to news Road pretty frequently I
have noticed this quite recently the one
at the road that's got the lighting on
even at night I didn't even know it was
there I can't see why this would add any
further light pollution particularly
given the street is lit anyway so I
haven't absolutely no problem with it
any further comment okay we have a
proposal to grant application 18 / 0 1
197 adv all those in favor this
committee resolves to grant the
application we haven't closed meeting
yet I'm just checking I take it there's
no urgent business the meetings closed
thank you